it was a simple perimeter scan  escorting  resources but we were ambushed by colon  raiders  fighters were no problem  but the missile frigates were a  different story  [Music]  [Music]  while another group found a tunnel in  the structure to sneak behind them  it worked  but just before a carrier battle group  arrived  we scrambled bombers  perfect for attacking capital ships  we protected the resourcers while they  hauled in the goods  which meant we could roll out assault  frigates  the raiders weren't pushovers but  command countered their hit and run  tactics  the way their carrier exploded  beautiful  and we even grabbed a little  souvenir  that missile frigate  is ours now  [Music]  you